[Music]
they call it little science versus big
science so the trend index science is
now okay well we're gonna have a mega
center of fifty million dollars a year
going to University of X and you know
one hundred scientists are all gonna be
working on this one gigantic project and
you know examples of doors or particle
physics experiments where you need a
huge amount of capital and government
funding is more towards more and more
big science and and little science is
kind of getting ignored small science is
you know individual investigators or
scientists thinking about an idea that
that is very risky you still don't know
whether it warrants 50 million dollars
worth of investment in terms of further
scientific inquiry but a little bit of
money could go a long way so when I
visited Capitol Hill I didn't feel that
there was a lot of scientific ignorance
going on but more like political
ideology as to how government funding
and where government funding should be
applied so for example when I described
the project that we were working on at a
time at and UC Berkeley and that was
being commercialized by my department of
energy into a real company some of the
people that we met in capital who
thought that government should not be in
the business of funding companies to
make products they thought that venture
capitalists should and my response to
that was well if you if you visit the
run of the mill you know Stan Hill Road
venture capitalists in the in the Bay
Area they're mostly interested in social
media kind of companies who was gonna be
Facebook who was gonna be the next
Twitter who's gonna be the next LinkedIn
who's gonna be in the next Google which
has a huge advertising revenue and so
there's two things there one is smaller
projects that have bigger impact and
societal impact kind of get ignored also
niche technologies that we can build on
for the future of things will not thrive
will go away a lot of the things that
were reaping the benefit of today was
because of the basic scientific research
that we funded in the 60s and 70s and
80s so if we stop
doing that kind of funding by the
government after a while it we just
won't have anything to build on top of
we'll just be advertising and to each
other and and connecting with each other
social media and that's that's it and
that's not what we want to end out so
there is a role for government in terms
of promoting scientific research for
both the sake of scientists and also for
commercializing those the scientific
research government is the this is the
only entity that can take a slightly
longer point of view in terms of these
developments but I think it's it's good
for for that to happen because sometimes
good ideas need a little bit of funding
before they can become bigger ideas
[Music]